[Music]
my name is Tom I'm product manager on
the Google Play console and I'm joined
onstage by my good friend Tamsin she is
head of business development for Western
Europe and also Dario who is a lead
engineer on the console as well now the
three of us represent teams who really
have only one job and that job is to
build products to help people just like
you build better apps better games and
ultimately better businesses on Android
and with Google Play that's what we and
our teams think about literally every
day I think it's worth kind of saying
about what that actually looks like for
a second at its heart what it looks like
is talking to people like you find out
what your needs are find out what kind
of insights you want take you back to
the teams and then passing over three
billion events a day that are generated
by Google Play and turning all of these
events and all this amazing data into
metrics insights and tools that you can
use to make better decisions to the
heart of the job and what all of you do
on a day to day basis is make loads and
loads of decisions about your business
about your acquisition about your
development and about your product
roadmaps
and it's our job to get you the
information you need to make those
decisions well because a good decision
is founded on good insights and good
data this is a really big job I mean the
three billion should give you a good
idea about that but there were loads and
loads of different ways you can go about
it and loads of ways you can think about
it as well now I'm sure all of you and
your companies think about this kind of
challenge every day and you'll have your
unique ways to do it now the way that
Tamsin Dario and I think about it is
around a mental model of a user
lifecycle it's probably quite familiar
to a few of you now the user life cycle
starts with discovery and acquisition
the first phase of building a business
in getting a user onto your Apple game
is to get them aware of you in
first place discovering acquisition is
all about getting in front of the user
persuading them that you've got a really
interesting game or app you've got a
really interesting product they want to
use and eventually persuading them to
tap on that button and installing it
after the install kind of ikana feel is
where the fun begins right cuz after the
install you get engagement and
monetization this is where people are
coming back to your products every day
they're opening them they're loving them
they're loving all the work that you and
your teams have done and hopefully
they're also paying you as well your
monetize them it would be great if this
were the end of the story if everybody
you acquired just used you again and
again and again and that was it but
unfortunately it's not because very
often for almost every user at some
point in the user lifecycle there's also
the uninstall the point where someone
for whatever reason decides to remove
you from their phone or tablet and then
they become a lost user it'd be really
sad if this was the end of the story as
well but increasingly the user life
cycle ends like this with persuading
people to come back again sorry to give
you a second or a third chance telling
them about the wonderful new features
you have that they want to try again
this is a sketch is how Austin our teams
think about the challenge in front of us
how do we get you the information you
need to be able to optimize each parts
of this as a sketch it's also very
simple and it's worth saying that there
are also quite negative parts of it as
well so for every person who discovers
you there's somebody who doesn't come
across you who doesn't find you and for
every person who finds you and installs
you there's another who for ever reason
choose not to install and even after
that for every person who becomes
engaged there's another who installs you
and doesn't use you all the time or
someone who does but eventually doesn't
monetize and then lastly for everybody
who you lose but choose to comes back
there's another one who is not convinced
to give you a second chance now the way
to win at this game the way to really
optimize your business is to minimize
all of the bad parts of the years of
lifecycle
and maximize all of the good parts and
that's what us and our teams do we build
tools and insights to help you make
decisions to maximize the good parts and
minimize the bad parts now the reason
the three of us are really excited to be
here today and to talk to all of you is
because over the last year since the
last i/o our teams have been building
successively more tools more insights
and more metrics to help you build more
successful businesses on play and on
Android and that's what we're going to
talk to you about today some of the
exciting launches we've made recently
that we made this week and it's a coming
up that help you optimize your user life
cycles so without further ado we're
going to start at the beginning of the
user life cycle we're going to start
with discovery and acquisition and for
that I'm really happy to welcome Tamsin
thanks Tom hi everyone my name is Tamsin
Taylor and I work in the business
development team for Western Europe now
I'm sorry guys but I think I'm actually
the luckiest person here because I get
paid to work with developers just like
yourselves every day I get to help them
understand their businesses better help
them under a dent my opportunities and
improve their business in a way is a
former product manager I'm living
vicariously through their success but
one thing which often comes up with
these partners it's the same question
how can I improve my discoverability how
can I get in front of more users how can
I stand out from the crowd in a nutshell
how can I get more installs does this
sound like something you're interested
in
excellent lots of nodding of heads well
you're in the right spot because in the
next 15 minutes I'm going to cover some
of the things that we're doing to make
or maximize your opportunities to be
found and I'm gonna go deeper to help
you understand how the your different
user acquisition channels and making a
contribution to your bottom line now if
everyone watched the keynote you would
have heard David Burke talk about how
Android has billions of users what you
might not know is in the last 12 months
the number of Android users who
downloaded a game more than doubled was
so what what does this mean for you it
means there's huge potential demand for
your app or game the question is how do
you get in front of those users so we've
been working really hard to make your
app even more discoverable and
accessible now when we think about
installs you might think about loading
your app into the Play Store once it's
in production and hoping for the best
well what if users could download your
app or game while you were still
building it
what if users could tell you that they
really wanted to download your app or
game that didn't currently exist in the
Play Store well we're working on a
couple of tools to answer these
questions the first is early access so
early access is a collection in the Play
Store of brand-new Android titles
running open beta those billions of
users I spoke about earlier they can all
download apps and games from this
collection and the great news is that
they can give private and actionable
feedback to the developer before you go
live so you can really tweak and
optimize your app to really maximize
your chance of success when you do go
live the second is pre-registration with
pre-registration you can put your app or
game into the Play Store but instead of
the install button it has a
pre-registration button now this is
fantastic because that means users can
opt in to have you tell them when your
app or game is ready and goes into
production so it's pre-registration or
helping support your efforts to start
marketing before you even go live and
it's been instrumental for top
publishers like Rovio who've been able
to get their fans really excited about
an upcoming release now if any of you
were here last year at i/o you might
recall we launched instant apps instant
apps help get your app in front of
people in more places more quickly and
with less friction
in March at the game developer
conference we launched Google Play
instant so Google Play instant is or web
go user see Google Play instant they can
download or access your instant app
whether it's the try now on the Play
Store through browsing searching or oh
thanks Tom
candy crush saga I'll try that in a
second so with Google Play Instant you
can just tap and try a game without
having to install the entire package so
whether you're looking to storm a castle
with clash Royale or become a word
master with words with friends - it's
just a really great way to help users
try your app or game without the full
commitment of downloading it so in this
way we're trying to help your
accessibility and your discoverability
and it really worked for hothead games
they actually saw a 19% lift in the
number of acquisitions after launching
with Google Play Instant so you can see
we're really trying hard to make it
easier for users to try before they buy
improve your discoverability and your
accessibility but that's all well and
good and you're in the right room and we
might be a bit biased but we think you
can only manage what you measure which
is why to support the launch of Google
Play instance and to help you understand
the contribution that this marketing
channel is having to a bottom line we're
really proud to announce brand new stats
in the Play console to help you measure
the success of your instant app feedback
from developers has been fantastic but
we did get some messages that you wanted
the stats to be more easily discoverable
so we've put them front and center in
the Play console and so now you can see
the number of launches and conversions
that your instant app has had what's a
conversion a conversion of the number of
times a user who's launched the instant
app then goes on to download it and
because the stats are in the play
console if you love playing with Daddy
you'll love this it means you can slice
and dice this information with your
other key metrics like insta
in revenue so it's pretty exciting so
you can now easily track the success of
your instant app on your overall growth
and today I'm really excited to announce
brand new capabilities in this reporting
you can now track which products across
browsers search and Play Store are
driving most of your instant app success
so you've got instant apps and now
you've got the fantastic reporting go
ahead and use it now there is so much
more you can do to increase your
discoverability on Android but I'm going
to stop there and say if you want to
learn more there's an adwords session on
the amphitheater stage right after this
so I think you'll all agree that not all
acquired users are the same it's really
important to acquire the right user for
your business the one that's going to
stick around for a long time the one
who's going to spend a lot of time in
the app and maybe the one who is going
to share your app with lots of friends
and spend money so it's really important
to capture the right users for your
business but how do you know whether
you're attracting the right users how do
you know whether you're spending your
time money and resources in the right
places to attract those users and once
you've got the users how do you know
that you're actually doing a good job
how do you know you're delivering them
value and where can you improve are
these these questions sound familiar I
hope so because the great news is we
have some updates to the acquisition
reports that will help answer these
questions they'll help you interrogate
understand and optimize your user
acquisition strategies to help your
bottom line so let's take a look so when
we think about these updates to the
acquisition reports we've really tackled
the three core questions that both
myself Tom and Dario hear from
developers every day and I know some of
you have asked me these questions quite
a lot so the first
how do people find my app or game on the
Play Store how valuable are the users
that I acquire through different
marketing channels and how am i doing
can I improve so let's tackle the first
one how do people find my app or game in
the Play Store now I know I've got some
partners in the audience and who I've
worked with quite a lot and one of the
comments I or questions I get about this
user acquisition report is hey Tamsin
you know that line that says organic
traffic what is that
who are these users where are they
coming from now organic traffic are
people who have come to your store
listing page not through deep links but
they might be browsing the Play Store
checking out collections seeing new
games and apps or they might be looking
for a specific use case like Tom here
might be looking for apps with museum
guides so we understand that this is a
really important channel for you and for
the majority of you it makes up the
lion's share of visitors to your store
listing page we also understand that App
Store optimization is really important
but developers like you haven't been
able to do much with this information to
date it's nice to see we don't really
know where they're coming from you can't
really optimize for it until now so in
response to all your requests I'm super
excited to announce the launch of
organic break downs in the user
acquisition report in the Play console
well done so now you can see for users
who've never installed your app before
which ones are coming from browsing the
store and which ones are searching now
just imagine how your growth or
marketing teams can leverage this data
to better present your app or game in
fact SCOE found that breakdown gave them
the ability to focus on the acquisition
areas that mattered so what does this
mean
okay well let's take an example let's
say you all after this open your
laptop's not now I'm speaking and you go
to the user acquisition report and you
click on this breakdown and you see oh
my god
90% of my organic traffic is coming from
browse what should I be doing well you
could probably imagine that some of
these people who are coming from
browsing might not be familiar with your
brand your value proposition or what
makes you different from your
competition so there's a great
opportunity there once you know this to
optimize your store listing I'll talk
more about that in a second the other
great news with this data is that we've
extended it so you can track the users
across the whole funnel across
subscriptions buyers and retained
installers so this really gives you more
insights into how those two channels are
driving traffic and what kind of users
they are and it gets even better and if
you're a marketing person in the room I
think you'll be super excited about this
you can now click through and see which
search terms are driving the most
visitors to your store listing and which
convert best so that is super exciting
it's a view into the Play Store which
we've never been able to share before
and it's something you've asked us for a
little I think at least three and a half
years that I've been working in this
team so thank you to the guys who built
it and I really hope you find it useful
because certainly our other pilot
partners have one thing we try and do
with this information we share with you
is make it actionable and give you
insights that help you make better
decisions as Tom mentioned earlier so we
were really happy to get feedback from
fun games for free about the relevance
of the longtail searches and what I love
to hear from Evernote is how they found
that data really actionable again we
want to give you data that's going to
help you make better decisions to grow
your business on play so developers said
that they loved this new feature and
because we tested it with quite a few
partners I thought given that you're
here today and
the effort to come along I'd share with
you some of the things which they're
going to use this information for in
case it sparked some ideas in your own
head so majority of the developers we
tested with said they would use this
data to evaluate their user acquisition
strategies a lot of them said they would
use it to optimize their store listing
so changing their descriptions their
screenshots and some even said they
would redesign their onboarding flow so
that the features benefits and whatever
else people are searching for are
reflected in that first-time user
experience to make it even more relevant
for that person when they install the
app so we're really pleased did our
developers found this useful and I hope
you will as well and I hope that answers
your question how do people find my app
or game in the Play Store now the
marketeers in the room might have found
that to be super exciting but the next
part is my favorite so if you care about
paying people on time if you care about
running a good business if you're a CFO
or a product manager you probably care
about acquiring valuable users which is
why I will tackle the next question how
valuable are the users that I'm
acquiring through different marketing
channels now a lot of the developers I
speak to tell me they love the user
acquisition report but installs are any
part of the story I'm sure you'll agree
they tell me that retention purchases
and subscriptions are leading critical
indicators of that one metric you all
care about revenue so today we're
launching a brand new item in the buyer
acquisition report our Pugh average
revenue per user so now you can see
exactly how much average revenue per
user you're getting from different
marketing channels and that includes the
organic traffic breakdown I spoke about
earlier Google search and third-party
traffic so if you're responsible for
setting the user acquisition strategies
in your business
or you're responsible for making sure
you have a profitable company this
information will help you make the right
decisions so no matter whether you're
running a classical CPM model cost per
install model or you're driving value
further down the funnel we really think
this information will help you evaluate
your existing strategies and make better
decisions moving forward now lastly on
acquisition I know there's a few of you
in the room who always say to me hey
Tamsin how am i performing against my
competition how can I do better how can
I improve
now benchmarks are really important and
we totally understand they're really
valuable to help you won't identify
where the room for opportunity is versus
the market and where you're already
smashing it out of the park and doing a
great job
in other words benchmarks are great
because they can help you focus your
investment on the items which will give
you the best return so for all these
reasons we were really happy a month ago
to launch the retained installers
benchmarks in it the user acquisition
funnel so now for all organic traffic
you can easily see throughout the user
journey from install conversion all the
way through to 30-day retention exactly
where the opportunities are for you to
improve or where the impact or the
efforts you've had have really paid off
and we've got a lot of happy developers
who have tested this with us including
into it and not dopler who've used it to
really tweak their conversion and get
improvements there or in the case of not
dopler finding out that actually all the
efforts that they put in have really
paid off
one thing I mentioned earlier that I
love about this this this feature and
all these you could user acquisition
reports is it they're not just here to
tell you where you're going wrong
they're here to give you a reference
point and give you confidence in your
decision-making which is why I was
really happy to see the quote from play
dots who told us that they love the
extra validation and confidence they get
on their own decision making
so the new tools that we've launched
help you get discovered instant apps and
pre-registration get your apps in front
of users like never before and if you
talk to us we'll say the most important
thing about this is we've launched new
reporting to help you optimize for it
updates these requisition reports give
you the data that you've never had
before to make much better informed
decisions around your App Store
optimization your acquisition investment
and to really help you drive and acquire
more valuable users right so now you
have the right users but how are you
going to keep them engaged and how are
you gonna monetize them well for this
exciting part of the talk let me hand
over to my esteemed colleague
Dario thanks thumbs in great to be here
so new tools help you get discovered and
the acquisition insights help you find
and acquire more and more valuable users
now what about helping you in the next
stage of the user lifecycle journey like
engagement and monetization how can we
help you engage your user more and earn
more money from them I'm glad to say
that we have some new tools to help with
that
so first off earlier this year we
launched the events timeline the events
timeline gives you contextual
information close to charts in the
statistics page in the Android vitals
dashboard in the subscription dashboard
and other chart surfaces on the Play
console showing you key events that may
affect your app such as for example the
rolling out of a new release this way
you can quickly spot correlations
between changes in matrix and such key
events for example you can understand
whether there are change in average
rating correlates with our rollout of a
new release or whether a price change is
affecting and how it's affecting the
average revenue per user or if you use
this on top if an instant up
configuration change such as mobile
holdback is affecting your sessions
positively or negatively
early adopters of these features loved
it
one developer in particular told us that
they were able to quickly understand why
a certain metric
spiked in a certain country so de Vence
timeline help you solving these
mysteries like with quicker like without
having to dig into other dashboard or
other or other data once you have
acquired your user you might want to
check how users are engaging with your
app Phi base offers great tools for
specifically for this purpose in
particular Google Analytics for firebase
can be enabled just by linking the
analytics SDK to your app and signing up
to the service of course and out of the
box it will give you already meaningful
metrics about engagement and retention
of the users what's also interesting is
that you can instrument Europe
instrument your code to track the
features that matter the most to your
app another really cool feature that the
firebase team launched earlier this year
is firebase predictions virus
predictions uses data coming from
analytics and our machine learning
knowledge and tools to give you
predictions about how the user the your
users are going to behave in your app
and like Google Analytics just by
enabling out-of-the-box you will get
predictions about a user span and user
churn and you can take some actions on
these predictions and similarly you can
also instrument your app to get more
personalized prediction that you care
about if you want to learn more about
Google Analytics for firebase you can
check out the session later today on
stage 6 so our friends Steve my and Russ
from the firebase team will present the
latest feature of Google Analytics for
five ways there is an entire truck for
firebase tools so I encourage you to
check it out if you're interesting in
particular for firebase prediction there
were two sessions yesterday that in case
you've missed
they are already available on YouTube
right so the advanced timeline gives you
key events and lets you correlate them
with your metrics firebase gives you
insight and marshal and increment
predictions
about behavior of your user let's dive
more now into the monetization phase
which after all is probably the most
critical phase because it's where you
earn the money and your business
actually start succeeding right we've
done a lot of work recently especially
on subscriptions so I'm gonna present
the latest things that we launched there
last year at i/o we launched the
subscription dashboard loads of
developers use the subscription
subscription - on a regular basis we are
in fact really proud that the majority
of top earning subscription businesses
actually use this dashboard on a regular
basis - but we heard that you wanted
more so this is why yesterday we
launched additional features in their
retention and in the cancellation report
let's take a quick look so in the new
retention report we have redesigned it
to make it super easy to compare cohorts
evaluate key features like free trials
and also track the data that are
important to you like renewals the new
cohort selector allows you to pick
groups of users selecting them by SK use
date and/or country so you can really
concentrate on a group of suscriber
and analyze their performance for
example you can pick and SKU with a free
trial and compare it with an Escalade
with an introductory price and see which
one of the two ends you more revenue
over time or you can also focus on last
year big marketing push and compare it
with these years and see which one
performs better for you
advanced cover comparison enables you to
explore all of this kind of intricacies
that's not although we extract a key
data that we know you're interested in
to make it easier than ever to track a
conversion because conversion that's
actually what matters to you so free SIA
success rate and other information about
performance are available right there on
the on the subscription dashboard and
because that you know the subscription
businesses live on repeated payments we
also tell you for each code you selected
which billing periods they reach
on today cancellation report we also
made major updates there to help you
reduce your subscription churn so users
can cancel for many reason and we
extracted the key technical ones out but
as we announced yesterday we now show
the users survey when the cancel so that
they can explain why they're constantly
and the result of this survey are
available on the subscription dashboard
so you will have more qualitative
insights directly from the users about
why they are canceled in the
subscription with your service lastly
we're reporting on wind back feature
features like account hold and grace
period which by the way you should check
out if you haven't already because we
heard from developers that it really
helped them and increase the increase
the retention of their subscribers so
these major updates help you
subscription businesses like hopefully
some of you here in the audience to
better understand and optimize
monetization such a key part of the user
lifecycle there was a session yesterday
but our four by our friends Larry Angela
and Miko about the this new advanced
feature about on the advanced and
advanced Google Play features for
subscription specifically so if you are
interested you might want to check that
as well on YouTube so lastly as Tom
introduced at the beginning the last two
phases of the user life cycles are
uninstall and win back play console
provides you with reports about an
install so for example the daily
uninstall matrix or the uninstall events
matrix or they retain installed in
installers acquisition report in which
you can check how long users keep your
app installed before uninstalling but we
heard you want more and we understand
why because this is such a critical
phase especially as your business grow
and also we don't have enough
information for you in our at the moment
for wind back so I'm happy to say that
we are working hard on this aspect and
we will introduce later this year some
more methods in this side specifically
for these steps
the user lifecycle journey so for
example we you will be able to analyze
how many unique users are uninstalling
your app over a certain selected time
period and also how many users are
installing your app again after having
uninstall it at some point in the past
so stay tuned for more updates so this
concludes our overview of how play
console and firebase can help you
analyzing your user lifecycle journey
thank you very much for AI attention for
your attention and now back to Tom
thanks Terry hello again so as Darion
Thompson shared the teams were working
really hard to build more tools more
insights and more metrics to help you
run better businesses build larger apps
and have happier and larger number of
gamers all of this work I think it's
fair to say we're extremely proud of
like deeply proud of the teams who
delivered it but all of this work also
in some ways causes a problem because we
also understand that all of you are
really busy you've got so many tools
both provided by us and others there are
loads of different places you can do you
can go and loads and loads of calls on
your time we understand that you're busy
and we understand that you need it to be
easy to see what the console has to
offer you and what's important and what
can be passed over we understand this
problem that's why really happy to say
that yesterday we launched the news of
the new apps dashboard in the Google
Play console let's take a really quick
look at what it's like the apps
dashboard is the landing page you sign
into the console you land here if you
select an app it gives you an overview
of all of your key data now previously
there wasn't quite enough data have we
heard that from all of you and it wasn't
really well organized and we've changed
all of that to start with we've
introduced really really easy to see
trending information so if you want to
know if your installs and moving in the
right direction it's now super easy to
see that if you want to take a quick
look to see if your technical
performance is going well and your
crashes are reducing you can see that
really easily as well
so trends first thing really easy to
glance at secondly we understand and we
heard from you that a lot of data
belongs together installs and uninstall
should be displayed together you might
want to take a look at your revenue and
your ARPU at the same time to answer
that challenge we sectionalized the
dashboard we've added a load more
information but we've also put it into
context so if any of the questions down
the left hand side of the screens feel
familiar these the questions the
dashboard specifically asks and
specifically answers now I'm sure that
many of you reading these and thinking
you know what that one's really
important to me I don't know I'm a QA
and I really really want to understand
what people think of my app through
reviews and how my technical performance
with core Vitus is going but maybe you
care slightly less about how your
pre-registration campaign is going or
maybe on this a day basis you don't look
at revenue we understand that having all
of this in our dashboard is sometimes
overwhelming and sometimes frankly not
all of it is relevant to all of you
that's why the new dashboard is also
customizable because every section you
see on the dashboard can now be expanded
or collapsed so if you're specifically
interested in your revenue you can have
that section open and it will give you
more and more useful information and if
you're less interested in
pre-registration you can have that
section collapsed remember your
preferences so it stays exactly as you
leave it it's a really lightweight way
of making the dashboard work for each
and every one of you personally we've
been testing this as we test everything
and a lot of the developers who will be
working with we're really happy with the
changes if I'm honest as a p.m. I'm not
sure quite how to take this quote but
the lead engineer from blue apron was
really really happy that there was a
simple place to direct their product
manager so they could see the questions
that they always ask really easily
answered by the dashboard and similarly
DocuSign very busy people were really
happy with the customization that we
give customization that doesn't
completely remove things there's no
flavors missing out but does mean that
borders focused for what you need right
now that's a really short overview of
all of the changes we've made to the app
- and hopefully when you log in today
and you see the new board you'll be able
to see all of that and how it helps you
in your day-to-day lives and frankly how
it helps you see the metrics and
insights that the console has to offer
to really help you so just to round out
where we are
daro Thompson myself and our teams
think about the user lifecycle and we
think about all of the different tools
that we can build to help you optimize
every stage from instant apps and
pre-reg for discovery and acquisition
through two brand new subscription
reports enhanced acquisition reports the
new events timeline and even the
uninstall stats and more information
coming soon about when back we think
that all of this taken together will
really help drive your success and
ultimately your success is what we work
towards that's what we're here to help
and all of this and other things like
the technical performance are wrapped
together with the app dashboard as well
so we're almost at the end of our time
together and there are just a couple of
more things to say first off we really
want your feedback so if you like the
session and even if you didn't then log
on to the URL and tell us what you
thought because it helps us make these
sessions better year after year after
year and lastly thank you so much for
listening from Tamsin Theriot the teams
and myself it's great to see so many of
you here and thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]